progress it's the reason that your
grandparents views are better not spoken
in public oh why did I bring you to
Straight Outta Compton pop up this is
this is partly on me in the recent
Republican presidential debate there was
a genuinely encouraging sign because the
subject of gay marriage came up and
presidential candidate John Kasich
responded like this guess what I just
went to a wedding of a friend of mine
who happens to be gay because somebody
doesn't think the way I do doesn't mean
that I can't care about him or I can't
love them Wow
a gay wedding just got applause at a
Republican debate add that to the list
of things that would have been
unthinkable in 2004 like the phrase
Academy Award winner Matthew McConaughey
would have said you were insane and it's
not just Kasich Jeb Bush Rick Perry
Bobby Jindal and Marco Rubio have all
said they would attend a gay wedding if
invited which I can only imagine is
terrible news for any of their gay
acquaintances who invited them only on
the assumption that they were declined
to attend and send a very expensive gift
instead well I didn't think he would say
yes did I mark now now which of your
friends wants to sit with Bobby Jindal
yes your friends are like my friends
although not all of the candidates have
been quite so clear Governor Scott
Walker for instance had a much more
squirrelly response would you attend a
gay wedding well in terms of that's a
certainly a first place for a family
member taught by our family are we got a
family member who's had a reception I've
been at a wedding but one
marriages still is defined between a man
the woman I support the Constitution the
state but for someone I love we've been
at reception what it's a yes or no
question how the hell did you respond on
the RSVP card when it asked if you
wanted chicken or fish well that's
certainly a personal question for dinner
at Annette and I already had chicken it
was at a restaurant not our home last
week I believe I haven't had fish
recently though I said I still believe
it is certainly a meal which is my
position although according to the menu
there is also maybe a vegetarian option
so to answer your question I have eaten
chicken in the past yes well well the
idea of a gay wedding is increasingly
widely accepted it is worth noting that
there are still a number of surprising
ways to ruin a gay honeymoon today in
most states an LGBT person can get
married on Saturday
posts photos of their wedding on Sunday
and they get fired from their job or
thrown out at their apartment on Monday
just because of who they are okay that's
clearly terrible
the only possible reason you should be
fired from your job after your wedding
is if your theme was stolen office
supplies that's the only logical reason
but it is true that discriminating
against gay people is surprisingly legal
in much of the country the fact is in 31
States people are at risk of being fired
evicted or refused service just because
they're gay so while federal law may
guarantee a gay couple's right to get
married it offers exactly zero
guarantees about their rights to do the
things that normally follow that like
signing a lease on an apartment they
can't afford or conducting tense
discussions about finances in the
brightly lit tapas restaurant of their
choosing or marching into any bank and
applying for a small business loan to
get Brenda stupid cupcakes for dogs or
idea off the ground
Brenda all cupcakes are cupcakes for
dogs they eat their own Brenda
which is just as well because your
cupcakes are terrible
they're terrible be if you are surprised
by this don't worry you're not alone a
2013 poll showed that nearly 70% of
people thought it was illegal under
federal law for someone to be fired for
being gay people believe it because it
feels like it should be true it's
optimistic but wrong like thinking
vertical stripes are flattering or
making your first condom purchase
magnums optimistic but statistically
wrong and there are plenty of recent
real-life examples of discrimination
happening just look at Colin Du Barry
and Kelly Williams a Texas couple who
made the mistake of visiting a
restaurant called Big Al's where their
waitress had something to say to them
she said that we don't serve can I think
bags here
we don't serve here then the
waitress continued they say here at big
girls we like for men to act like men
and for ladies to act like ladies and it
was just so nonchalantly like I like
almost like she was reading a piece of
paper well she was that phrase is posted
on the front door of the restaurant
she's young lady didn't know what else
to say and they just kept on she finally
said and she said we just thought okay
that is obviously appalling and also
someone might want to tell Big O that
having a sign saying when men act like
men is actually the single gayest thing
imaginable so that's an example of
recent discrimination regarding public
accommodation for discrimination in the
workplace take the case of Casey steagle
a gay man employed as a children's
social services worker also in Texas his
fiancee showed up to help him one day
because he was overseeing a field trip
and wanted assistance and the next thing
he knew this happened well later in that
week I got a text message from the
president of children's home saying I
need to come meet with him and then told
me because of my lifestyle choices he
didn't feel comfortable having me on his
team anymore
for the record being gay is clearly not
a lifestyle choice a lifestyle choice is
when a man gets obnoxiously into jazz or
goes on an Atkins
diet and starts a food blog called
protein wolf both of which you should
actually be fired for but that's not
what we're talking about here tonight
the fact is this kind of discrimination
can have ripple effects like when this
Michigan couple had their pediatrician
refused to treat their baby just because
they were lesbians which as they point
out is crazy
we're not your patient she's your
patient and the fact that you can't your
job is to keep babies healthy then you
can't keep a baby healthy that has gay
parents exactly but to be fair no one
can keep any baby healthy regardless of
the parents babies are fleshy bacteria
magnets
they're basically vomits volcanoes
they're going to get sick and they're
going to make you sick that's just a
fact but it is amazing that any of those
stories are taking place in this day and
age and I'm not saying that this is the
case everywhere some states and cities
do have good protections and I suppose
we could wait for every state to catch
up but there are certain issues too
important to be left to the states
specifically civil rights and state
birds
you chose the scissor-tailed flycatcher
Oklahoma are you kidding me
how do not go with the Eastern Phoebe
That Bird is a pure winged Majesty but
you went to chose a piece of garbage
with a beak it looks like it fell out of
Miranda July's hair that's a barn
Oklahoma shame on you you're on the
wrong side of history
anyway the point is states have a
checkered history when it comes to civil
rights just look at Arkansas right now
not only do they not have any
anti-discrimination ordinances earlier
this year they actually passed an anti
anti-discrimination ordinance that
prevents any city or county from
extending civil rights protections to
gay people here is a sponsor of that law
explaining why I want to be treated
equal just like I want someone from the
LBGT community to be treated equal I
want to be fair to them and I want to be
fair to me they shouldn't get more
rights than I do and I shouldn't get
more rights Amil what are you talking
about this is not about special rights
we're not creating lesbians only
sections on airplanes or putting up
signs at Six Flags saying you must be
this gay to go on this right this is
just basic equality that's all in it now
there have been some positive moves at
the federal level just last month the
EEOC ruled the Civil Rights Act applies
to LGB workers and a year ago the
president added LGBT protections for
federal contractors all of which is
great but those protections could be
undone by his successor and it's worth
noting two of the Republican governors
running for president actually weakened
their state's non-discrimination
policies Bobby Jindal let an executive
order expire and John Kasich kept his
but removed the protections for
transgender workers for some reason and
it must be strange to live in a state
and see progress actually move backwards
it'd be like if apple suddenly
introduced the iPhone 7 and it was a
flip phone so that's still not as dumb
as the Apple watch but it's done
not that dumb but done now the main
argument against extending these
protections is that it might infringe on
religious freedom forcing people to act
against their religious beliefs
hence the rise of Religious Freedom
Restoration Act around the country and
religious freedom is not an inherently
bad thing and I'm not just saying that
because I'm the current mega Reverend of
Our Lady of Perpetual exemption we allow
for religious freedom in limited
sensible ways all the time it's why
Muslims can wear a hijab in their
driver's license photo and why devout
Christians can't be forced to work on
the Sabbath but there are reasonable
limits to it and we've all heard it
mistakenly cited in stories like this
Colorado Baker Jack Phillips estimates
he's made 5,000 wedding cakes since he
opened his shop masterpiece cakes 20
years ago a deeply religious man Jack
Phillips says he'll bake birthday cakes
cupcakes and a variety of other sweets
for same-sex couples just not a wedding
cake I actually feel like I'm taking
part in the wedding part of me goes to
the reception parts of you goes to the
reception I have a horrifying sense what
that might mean in a way I've been
married five thousand times in another
way I come in the cake
[Applause]
that Baker denied service to a gay
couple in 2012 citing his belief that
providing them with a wedding cake would
offend his definition of traditional
marriage but that's a little hard to
square with the fact that he allegedly
had no problem providing a cake for a
wedding between two docs and look those
dogs may lick their own balls but I'm
sure even they are now regretting
ordering a vanilla cone cake from the
ejaculating Baker of Colorado but but
the bigger flaw in his argument is his
understanding of how the law works the
Constitution guarantees me the right to
practice my faith my religion anywhere
anytime there are no restrictions on it
it also gives me the right to free
speech anytime anywhere except it
doesn't though courts have already
decided there are limits on religious
freedom for example they found that you
can't discriminate on race based on your
religious beliefs and there are limits
on free speech you can't yell fire in a
crowded theater the Constitution isn't
the star in Super Mario Brothers
it doesn't make you invincible so you
can just do whatever the you want
now just so you know that Baker lost his
case because Colorado happens to be one
of the states that has a law banning
discrimination based on sexual
orientation and when states have those
laws even states with religious freedom
acts cases do now tend to go gay
people's way which is good the problem
is there are still way too many states
that don't have anti-discrimination laws
at all so maybe it's time we just fix
all of this nationwide in one go and
interesting there is something called
the Equality Act in Congress right now
which adds LGBT protections to the Civil
Rights Act the Fair Housing Act and
several others it has over 200
co-sponsors in the House and Senate
unfortunately precisely 0 of them are
Republican which is genuinely difficult
to do for instance there's an actual
bill that just designated September the
25th as national lobster day even that
had two Republican co-sponsors and look
I'm not saying lobsters don't deserve
recognition from our governments
because they absolutely do although do
they that's not the point
that's not the point the point is this
bill represents the bare minimum of not
being discriminated against and this
should be what represents the threshold
of true gay tolerance not whether or not
you would consider attending a gay
wedding so we actually reached out to
every single presidential candidate from
both parties and asked them would you
support passage of a federal law all
laws that prohibit discrimination based
on sexual orientation and gender
identity specifically in the areas of
employment housing public accommodations
and access to credit it's not a
complicated question it's a long
question yes but it's not a complicated
one but only four campaigns got back to
us lincoln Chafee and martin O'Malley
said yes they would but to be honest I
think they were just happy anyone had
asked them anything
so discount that Bernie Sanders also
said he would and a spokesman for rand
paul said and this is true we'll pass
thanks okay you're welcome
everyone else is presumably still
thinking about it but why we reached out
on Thursday and it should not take that
long to work out the answer to should
gay people be discriminated against is
just know that's it because it is long
past time that gay people had the same
rights that straight people have namely
to be fired because they're being
replaced by a computer to be denied
service at a restaurant because they're
neither wealthy looking nor attractive
and more specifically to have a wedding
cake but not eat it because they suspect
a strange man may for some reason have
ejaculated into it
you